warning this video contains many
flashing lights and colors if you're
prone to epilepsy please watch with
caution
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play a mother's
inferno okay this is a horror game that
I found on my desktop and I've no idea
how it got there so let's get started
okay don't need to learn about the
controls oh hello this is exceptional
hey what the hell no my son okay I'll
get my son back I'm gonna put an
epilepsy warning on the beginning of
this video okay yeah I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got it gotta get my
son back what the hell just happened
normally with my son I am a mama I'm um
whoa you know I didn't I don't know I
didn't know this game when I downloaded
it so I was not expecting anything like
this is exceptionally well made but
obviously the wool hello okay then what
the hell whoa what the I got a fleece
piece of glass what am I gonna do with
this
mama fly someone up huh will the shard
cut deep remove this head off my body
okay
what raah
I'm gonna getcha maybe what the hell
whoa okay so what what is what am i
doing karate chopping the [ __ ] out of
you weirdo take on yeah I'm trying I'm
doing that do I not have a glass shard
anymore need to get oh wait no hang on
what did I just do yeah her chow we grab
first and strike there we go got it why
did I do that
I am the guy through this hell what what
do you what the hell
I'm a mad mama
I'm an angry biz kid or what what you
got nothing that's right get out ahh did
it get me what what am i grounded come
on bug grab you by the big throat and
just dry cow got you just gotta be head
everything I see
is that how I operate in this theater of
death and destruction okay running away
thank you ha ha ha ha ha whoa what the
what are you doing to that guy there the
River Styx roars in front of you because
celestial injustice or justice leap on
my back and I will haul you across okay
I'm on I guess this is perfectly normal
what is going on here I'm so confused
thank you kind sir I guess thank you
trained person what a squirrel is in
whoa what is that what the hell what's
going on here hi what's going on over
there
Wow what the hell where'd you come from
do I get to chop off your head oh I see
I see it I'm gonna get God I see it chop
it chop it chop it good
I said chop it oh I done I done goofed
I don't you okay ready oh hey come here
I've got a word okay I'm gonna chop the
[ __ ] out of you
stabby stabby stabby stabby stabby
stabby stabby stabby stabby okay stabby
can i still stabby stabby anyway oh okay
we're gonna hand I need to go over here
oleh dumped up the fender
get on stabby some more I'm run the
boulder justice land how did this even
happen
oh that's what I want to know Olay aah
oh I got me I was so stupid
okay I was dumb there all right I was
whoa what was that
what the hell is that hey cutie Oh gimme
pardon my sneezing I apologize I'm more
professional than that
does that mean that someone's talking
about me if I sneeze sound like that
okay I think finish it off now get it
get it okay it's good it's gone now all
right
perfectly normal nothing strange
happening here who made this game that's
what I want to know though this savage
to led us to send now into blindness the
savage darkness will find your son okay
alrighty then I couldn't exactly see
what was gone on before so I don't know
how there's gonna help me now oh sorry
another monster oh hi hello everybody
how are you doing you're doing good
today how you doing hey how's it going
I'm a mother I'm one bad mother
are you do I get to kill you do I get to
stab you in the eyeball Oh what am i
doing
I think I'm gonna have a seizure in this
game this is ridiculous hello
what did I do I see a red globe whoa
what are you trying to tell me I can't
see you self how there's a red glowy
thing over here that I can now see in
the darkness whoa what the
maybe I just went on uh some kind of
crazy psychotic you you get your head
chopped off what whoa
whoa what the hell oh you got to me
across the river or sticks I don't know
I don't know don't ask me I am so
utterly confused I literally have
nothing that I could possibly say about
this because it doesn't make any sense
at all but I'm so enraptured by it it is
so cool I don't even know what's
happening and I'm I'm it's so cool it's
so weird but so cool what the hell is
going on here
hello I got nothing to say because I've
never seen anything like this I've
literally I don't know whether to be
terrified or amazed because this is
incredible
did I reach a dead end or something was
that what are you leo
pooja who hoop ja ho ho you're a snail
are you a snail but chomp ah
oh I see a handle okay I got it I'm on
the snail I think whoa what the I can't
even see what's going on anymore
everything got blurry and out of focus
and the colors went wrong inverted I
guess
and this be over soon I'm guessing if I
had to guess at what happened there was
a train accident and the Sun went flying
and the mom and the son died but the mom
is in limbo trying to find her son
perpetually I don't know it's all so
weird and so confusing that I don't
really know what to say about okay am I
done if I finish my journey mr. snail
okey dokey
thank you mr. snail don't know where you
took me exactly but thank you I keep
getting flashes of me stabbing the
monsters that I was stabbing before
through he through her is the way to
eternal glean no thank you you get your
head stabbed okay no you don't yeah I
know weird visions constantly seeing my
son just be what was that
oh okay down the stairs we go that's all
I can say now what the hell that's all
like stab you stab it I stab you all of
the times you're like a combination of
all the notches I just killed aren't you
oh you're freaky oh you're freaky now
you're freaky okay you're weird but
that's okay I see a thing on your back
and then I see a dotted line on your
neck and I see something on your crotch
so uh that's a little weird
gravelly waily waily we believe Wibbly
stabbed establish Dabish stab me in the
back okay that was three times in the
back that mean you're all good to go we
believe we believe we believe we believe
you okay how about I grab your crotch
now I stab you in the dick now what I
need to do do I need to cut off your
head now I sure wish I could see what
was going on we believe we believe we
believe we believe we believe and I
gotta grab you from the crotch your
backs already done I don't know what
more needs to be done there whoa I saw
that you almost tried to stop me never
I'd grab you by your big fruit and I
mean get this crop did I get you I got
him I got his neck oh he's still alive
why is he still alive
stab you in the crotch in the butt whoo
you got boobs don't you why do you have
boobs
that's so weird why do you have AB why
do you have boobs this is so wrong ha ha
ha
your heads gone and then I guess I just
the only thing left to grab his crotch
can't I can't grab it though yeah did I
get something I think I might have
gotten a little bit of something you
didn't get me no no no no no shaggy
shaggy shaggy shaggy shaggy and then run
I'm so disturbed right now these are the
games I play that is party stab the back
I've got nothing left to stop there
or maybe I should just keep stabbing the
back I really have no idea now maybe I
should just leave hey can you get out of
my way please cuz I don't really know
what I'm supposed to do here
she [ __ ] seriously you're so weird
you're so weird
tell me what to do to kill you I need to
know your heads gone all that's left is
this thing on your crotch I swear it so
what did I just do I grabbed something
I'm doing something what did I do
I did something hang on hang on I
grabbed I grabbed something like this
and then what am i doing
try not to get too close because she's
going to do that but yeah she's kind of
bleeding from her stomach of it
okay now she's going wiggly wobbly and
then she charges
she's pretty stupid I gotta say not
exactly the smartest thing in the world
and I'm doing something I don't know if
I'm affecting like her neck foreplay oh
man I'm not doing anything to this woman
how do I beat you
no no no no I don't know how to beat
this lady and I'm I see like some blood
from the stomach wah wah long did I get
it no I got hell yeah
I beat her oh yeah I am the woman I am
the sell my son soon did I get my son
yeah I got my son I think I couldn't see
what was happening that was really weird
not really weird no it's so weird I
don't even know what to say about that
but creative I guess man that's like a
whole different level of games that I've
never played in my life before so if you
enjoyed it let me know in the comments
below links in the description if I
could find where I downloaded it from
but thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation more videos it I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
on the right
yeah
okay
Oh
it's like standing five
the door closed on me [ __ ] okay all
right I'll go in the front of the class
mine's green
dark